oh my god I'm sorry they didn't have any
booths okay so I thought I tried to make
a space for you I didn't know how high
your chair was hold on you need some
help oh yeah oh I got it
I can like lift you Danny all right yo
that's funny to meet you in person
oh I can push myself alright damn zombie
night this one's on the house
you're so brave Thanks so are you hungry
yeah I heard this place is really good
Meghan jeez ya know so what happen to
your feet as soon as I saw on your
profile that you're an amputee I had to
messaged you do you know what a devotee
is yeah yeah hey girl I've got the
perfect guy for you
he just started out my job and he's in a
wheelchair
okay I'm like what else like 20 Bell oh
he sounds fascinating
excuse me where are you parking there
you see this handicap uh-huh sorry man
uh I don't I don't say sorry to me say
sorry to hurt my last girlfriend she was
missing an arm but it wasn't exactly
what I was looking for you now how do
you think she feels she has to come over
here and she sees a perfectly finally
end just dancing out of his car parked
in the handicap i'ma put you everywhere
you know what I'm exposed to right now
worldstar snapchat everything I got it
all there's our first date I'm trying to
impress her and then she gotta come over
here see this sorry it's fine just don't
park there together I think anybody
would give up their feet to get a
beautiful smile like yours this is very
embarrassing people to have the best
plantains in LA really look like I got
plantains anywhere anywhere they'd be
right in the back is there another
entrance
no what I don't even like this place you
know yeah
Ione has like four stars in you know you
go girl okay how does sex work for you
no you're funny you're beautiful and the
fact that you don't have either of your
feet just really does it for me
yeah like when you roll over a bumpy
road is there like a vibrator do you
come that way that makes no sense
have you ever had sex on the chair
capable of even going out with so many
creeps girl and like you don't date
creeps I guess there was that one guy
that wouldn't stop trying to touch my
hair - [ __ ] boys losers and weirdos
salud
champs I can't change